well inflation continues to impact
families forcing many to seek options
for food well today we dig into the
struggle that so many southern nevadans
are facing food insecurities it's a grim
reality that sometimes can't be solved
until you see the challenge firsthand
i haven't eaten a decent meal in like a
year robert wagner moved to las vegas
from chicago three years ago seeking a
better life but now he says he's down on
his luck chap is cutting our pay and
i won't pay for rent anymore and
ebt has been cut and all my benefits are
gone so
it's very hard to survive according to
the usda a single adult spends about 411
dollars a month on groceries the average
american spends on average of 8.6
percent of their disposable income on
food with inflation causing costs to go
up wagner says it's a struggle by the
end of the month i'm already broke so
i'm starving you know i'm not i'm not
eating for about a week you know yeah so
i gotta really
plan my food out you know and don't eat
as much as i want to eat
small businesses like this one near
arville and flamingo are key to
residents like wagner because they
accept ebt or wic from their customers
store manager sherman habibian says it's
a win-win for everyone it's a source of
revenue for the store and the other part
is to make it a little bit more
convenient for the people that are on
wicker ebt
to be able to come over here and pick up
some of the necessities that they do
need
with the government's assistance wagner
says he can pick up some of the basic
items to get by while he continues to
seek better job opportunities i get two
from here you know i get little tv
dinners
well according to three square there are
more than 363 thousand southern nevadans
experiencing food insecurity now on
august 27 in an 8 news now special we
will explore a series of food challenges
and how the valley is tackling this
problem so we hope you can join us